glorious are all day means all of us
will be the sole defender of our L we're
also going to have I thought to
verification talks but Zico is still
tossing coins thinking what happen that
we'll also have this ethnics will have a
couple ethics talk stay in this ethics
panel let me say that this is also a
wild card from me I'm very curious how
this will go
I've planted a number of questions up
here and feel free to throw in your your
own questions of course what I think
Cindy learning means is even quite
arbitrary so you have to start putting
hey can you like up here so yeah let's
go ahead and start with the first talk
so week on like I said OVR our soul
defender of course over
first off I would like to thank
organizers to invite me to come and talk
about work I'm gonna talk about
reinforcement learning why in
optimization lens in the talk in this
talk I would like to argue that there
are some really interesting and
fundamental research opportunities that
lie at the intersection or reinforcement
learning and optimization in particular
I wish we show that reinforcement
learning can be formulated as an
standard optimization problem with a
clear leader fun objective function that
can be easily estimated from data and
solved this idea may sound
straightforward to supervised learning
audience but in reinforcement learning
it turns out that the dominating
approaches these days are based on a
different approach different class of
approach and in this talk I will explain
why this is the case and what challenges
these current approaches face and how we
may solve it by an optimization lens
this talk has some it actually has some
of the some overlap with the talks
yesterday I'll talk about them when in
when I'm in the right slide so
reinforcement learning is about learning
to make decisions from data they're our
potential applications ranging from
games to control in and
human-in-the-loop systems when people
try to make reinforcement learning work
in practice there are a number of
research problems that are involved and
today I'm going to and particularly for
this talk I would like to take a very
boring but hopefully basic view of
reinforcement learning when we try to
apply it very similar to other areas of
mission learning when you apply
something to a real problem there are
three steps major steps one is data
collection one is data collection and
then use the data you train a model once
you have tomorrow you test the model how
good it is in the context of RL the
first step data collection corresponds
you doing
for extra efficient exploration and a
second is to learn a value function or
policy last one testing whether it pause
is good enough there's also the
correspond the counterpart called pause
evaluation and all three yellow boxes
are non-trivial research problems as it
turns out the majority of well many Aria
works these days are about online RL
where exploration of data collection is
part of the algorithms and for the
purpose of today I'd like to focus on
the the offline or batch RL part where I
assume that beta is given beforehand and
what I want to do is to make the best
use of data and learn the policy and and
this is a very different problem and for
today we're going to talk about the
second block which is Val function
learning from batch data and this is
helpful as it separates and different
challenges and we can focus on
particular problems and go deep into it
and also this is useful in even in this
by itself can be very useful in practice
and in the long run it can be used as a
as a component to solve the full online
reinforcement learning problem so this
is the that the area we're going to talk
about today and then so this is the
outline I'll first go through some of
these basic RL terminology and setup and
then I'll explain why the current
approaches don't get may go wrong in in
reality and then I'll go and I describe
a prime module formulation for
reinforcement learning as well as the
new Cardinal loss for for solving value
function learning problems so MVP MVP is
this Markov decision process it's a it's
a model that captures a class of
problems between interaction problems
between an agent and environment there's
a set of stage a set of actions and then
the agent can take an action in any
state and then transition to the next
day following some probability
and encourage the reward function for
that transition and there is a discount
factor and Gaurav Arielle is typically
to maximize the total reward discounted
by a gamma in the long run and then
here's a very simple perhaps to one of
the simplest example of MVP which is to
find a deterministic shortest path in a
finite graph so here that you can think
of the nose in a chronic reverse States
edges are actions that you can take from
that node and then cost associated with
each edge is the immediate reward with
the negative sign so if here we want to
minimize cost not maximize reward and we
want to find the shortest path with the
minimum cost that goes from the start
state to the goal State
if you solve this problem naively you
may want to you may have to enumerate
all possible paths from stores to target
this is very inefficient instead you can
take advantage of this recurrence
equation that tells you the minim cost
to go from any node I can be decomposed
as the sum of the one-step cost to one
of his neighbors plus the minimum cost
to go from that neighbor J and you have
to take a minimum over all the neighbors
and this is the idea behind the
principle of dynamic programming that
was discover decades ago by Bowman and
this this equation allows you to
decompose and potentially combinatorial
an exponentially large solution space
into a much smaller space and then solve
it more efficiently more generally we
have this Pearlman equation where now
instead of a shortest a final graph we
now have an MDP where the state space
can be infinite continues and the reward
function now we want to maximize reward
not a cost and a transition is not
deterministic but it can be stochastic
but the same I a principle of dynamic
programming applies and we end up with
the bellman equation that looks very
much like this one except that you need
to take expectation for the transition
and
for the purpose of this talk solving RL
is roughly equivalent is solving the
bellman equation for the battle function
the optimal value function V star so
this is the set up
let me introduce one more rotation the
bauman operator for to make the
following discussion easier this is the
Bioman equation the left hand the right
hand side can be thought of as an
operator that converts this value
function into a new function that is
defined as so that's how the bellmen
operator is defined for any function V I
can define the Baughman operator is that
this guy and above an equation is just
saying that V Star is the fixed point of
this Domino operator T it's saying the
same thing as previous slide this
Powerman operator has well known a nice
properties such as monotonic if you
apply two to two fellow functions one is
dominated by another the resulting value
of function is also dominated by the
other one in the same direction more
importantly it's a contraction meaning
that in Europe you have to value
functions we want to be two you apply
the bellmen operator you you're
guaranteed at the max norm of these new
functions are closer to each other than
the previous one by a factor of 1 minus
gamma so if you apply this operator
sequentially then you reach our
geometric convergence to something
called a fixed point okay and this
points turns out to be a unique fixed
point of and this the optimal value
function that we try to solve in the
first place and this is the mathematical
foundation of most of the recurrent
reinforcement learning algorithms
including different versions of value
iteration tdq learning and active
component synaptic critique if you can
solve this you can solve computers T
Domino operators exactly at least on
average then you guarantee that
eventually you can converse to the right
solution okay and these exact cases
roughly more or less the same as
assuming that the state space is finite
in many cases
so things so far seems to look good so
what can go wrong is that when bellman
meets cows where we try to approximate
the value function in a large state MVP
using a more compact perhaps Prometric
representation for example you may
represent in V Star is the linear
approximation the new network height and
then in order to represent the the new
value function after you apply
development operator which may so this
is the the new function after you
applied above an operator it may jump
out of the parametric family a function
that you can represent so you need this
extra step of projecting the new
function back to the class of functions
that you may represent using your new
network for example and this composition
of the two operators projection and
Powerman operator unfortunately loses
the contraction property the gamma
contraction that development operator
enjoys so what and has been known for
decades that you do this kind of a thing
then the value of the solution the value
function estimate may diverge it may
also late they may have different
behavior and they made a verge even for
very very simple problems there are
people have tried different ways to
solve the problem and and their success
in limited cases but in general this
remains a very hard problem so to give
you an idea why this could go wrong let
me show these classic example from
Chiklis and why you have to state
there's to stay MVP you want to
represent a value of the first day by W
and the second state's value by 2 W so W
is the single parameter to scalar that
you try to learn and suppose that your
sample stays X 1 X 2 uniformly from from
the isle of X 1 let's say you start from
a non zero W for the ID of X 1 let's say
W is 1 it it seems to be this it seems
to the agent that going from W to W to
its values should be bigger because now
after one step it gets $2 so and my
current estimate is one dollar after one
step I get $2 so I need to improve
increase my estimate for this state
because a bellman operator right so now
W is increased from 1 to something
bigger than 1 you can and and this state
has the will push the W down but if you
but if you're sampling distribution of
these two day that states are the same
then you can show that when gamma is not
too small then eventually the whole
system will be unstable and W will
reverse to infinity in other words when
you apply balm on operator there's some
pollution or some boost chopping effect
that makes the age and the food's the
agent so that the agent will think is
has more and more reward so that W can
reverse to infinity does it matter in
practice this is a very simple example
in practice like this can this does
affect practice so these are a few
typical examples from published papers
for example you apply DQ n on Atari
games you don't see you see this kind of
very unstable behavior which is versat
bit different from typical supervised
learning and learning curves sometimes
you see the little function going up and
down over time without convergence and
sometimes you see the value function
goes T the value goes up and then down
and then the it's changed and this this
divergence behavior and this remains a
long-standing open problem how to ensure
convergent dynamic programming in the
approximation case this is a perhaps the
oh well the oldest paper I can find it
that is about function approximation and
dynamic programming in 60 years ago so
the algorithmic ideas is not new but how
do you make sure that the algorithm is
stable and converging and reliable it's
it's a very challenging problem and they
so difficult that it has this famous
named call deadly triad by recession and
colleague and then there's some recent
efforts like emphatic tea
but it still remains unclear whether
they can solve this problem there also
the interesting work on removing
delusional bias in q-learning but I
think the focus is different from from
this work the focus there is about how
to ensure the policy class is consistent
between multiple steps but but here even
if you have a single action where which
means that there's no such delusional
bias you can this kind of converge non
stable behavior can still exist so so
these are the the problems where the
existing approaches can we solve it
using by reformulating at this
optimization problem and the answer is
yes the different approaches one is
linear programming this is the bargman
operate with a bellman equation it turns
out that it's equivalent to solving this
linear program we remember that the T
operator is a monotonic operator so this
constraint means that V is upper bound
uniform upper bound on V star point wise
upper bound and these objective means
that you want to make V as far as
possible
so when these two are combined the
solution it's like exactly the the value
function get try to resolve V Star and
there a number of works in the last
year's and yesterday professor Wang from
Princeton talked about this line of work
and we like to if you're interested you
please watch her talk and today I'm
going to focus on a different approach
that tries to solve the fixed point
directly again we go back to this
bellman equation you won't have saw the
fixed point a rare natural starting
point is this we want to minimize the
the discrepancy between the left hand
side and right hand side you minimize
this objective to zero day and as you
found a solution but why is this why
doesn't people do this why didn't people
do this before is because the objective
is not friendly you've already doubt you
have you notice that the two things one
is that there's a max operator that
makes the problem not differentiable
it's hard to optimize using gradient
descent for example the second thing
there is more subtile is that there's
this double sample problem hidden by
this conditional expectation so what it
means is that here the objective
function for this objective function you
need to compute a conditional
expectation for this guy so this is what
we need right this conditional
expectation you want to do great descent
on the parameter example but when you
observe the data the data is are all
usually in the form of state action next
state to pose s prime to pose so what
you end up doing using se square loss
minimization using VP in using empirical
data what you optimize is actually this
their expectation is outside of the
square knot inside so these two are
different and that difference gives you
a bias gradient and in practice they
make make your value function converts
to the suboptimal or wrong solution now
can we so how do we get around these two
challengers the first one it's well
people have used these ideas in
different contexts to use to introduce a
smoothing term entropy regularization so
here we have a max of all auctions about
in the Domino operator we can
equivalently write this max over action
as max over all policies without this
part yet okay and then this smoothing is
to add this regularization term so that
the policy that we find is will be
smooth meaning that it has nonzero
probabilities to all actions can for all
states and then we with this smoothing
we end up with a smooth bellman operator
T sub lambda this T sub lambda has a
nice property that is still a gamma
contraction so all these previous
results of Armin operators do you apply
that we have a
the unique solution we lambda star and
we can find it this new solution and the
previous solution we try to find are not
too different they are controlled by
this lambda in the leaf linearly more
importantly is this temporal consistency
condition that our Dale and colleagues
discovery in the path consistency
learning paper that says that with this
regularization you can show that for all
state action pair if you find a solution
then this can this equation holds for
all stay action even if even if the
action is not optimal so now you don't
you don't have to worry about the max a
max over a and in the objective function
because this is true for a so you can
sample a sample s sample a and then try
to minimize the discrepancy between the
left hand side right hand side of the
equation in the bottom there one of them
should be s prime here oh yeah sorry
yeah it's a type of
okay so so now we end up with this
consist this new equation which is from
this one I just there's the square error
between the left hand side right hand
side there's this one now I still have
this this conditional expectation inside
a square loss how do I transform it so
that I can be easily approximated by
sample empirical data so this is done by
using an legenda transformation
we do you know this whole thing here by
X sub s a and then I use the reverse
transform of the gender the conjugate
function and so that by introducing a
new variable Y for each variable X si
and then I end up with this new patient
problem that has this new variable and
notice that here the Y variable is a
scalar but here is a valve is a function
on stay action there's a sub
mathematical subtlety here from this
deputy step that depends on something
called interchangeability principle but
the idea is to use these transformation
to convert this X square function into
something that's linear next so that you
can easily estimate this quantity using
samples without having to worry about
the quadratic thing
so after this long journey we have not
reached this new minimax or prime module
formulation in a sense we turn a fixed
point of the barman operator into a
saddle point problem with this objective
function well well this guy it is the
bellmen operate at about manera and this
new is the newly introduced you variable
or dual function the good thing about
this formulation is that now we finally
have a clearly defined objective
function that can be easily estimated
from data and then once you estimate it
from sample you can do things like
stochastic rates and optimize it until
convergence and you may wonder how we
can solve this max in a max you can do
different kind of things for example
when in when new is parametrized in a
concave wait and the inner max can be
solved exactly or you can do is to time
scale updates so that you can reach a
stationary point but the kind of the
guarantee is weaker at least there's
something you can do different kind of
thing by injecting different structures
to make this problem easier to solve and
by the way this we've been talking about
square loss of valve an error but you
can see that the same idea can be
applied with other convex loss function
as well
and the resulting I algorithm is quite
straightforward at this point once you
reach this formulation essentially what
you try to do is to parameterize the two
variables and primal variables three
things involve by say new networks and
do green descent on great design green
design on the primal and dual variables
and you convergence and then
another benefits of looking at the
problem frame in a problem is
optimization problem is that now you can
employ some of these standard techniques
from statistical learning to analyze the
behavior statistical behavior and
optimization behavior of the algorithm
for example that's this guy this is the
true value function this is the solution
I found using the previous algorithm
after running it for n iterations W is
my parameter to learn and I can
decompose this error into unist and away
like optimization error statistical
error approximation error and this
smoothing bias that I have introduced
and you can quantify an upper bound
these different quantities using very
standard techniques and then you can you
can analyze what they when and how the
algorithm work so these are pretty
standard so I'm going to skip it and you
can for example you can get a standard
convergent finite sample convergence
rate under certain assumptions I would
like to make puts have give some remarks
on related work
this is ideas similar to Bowerman of
stage of minimization although in the
mean this previous work it the focus is
on policy evaluation meaning that
there's no the false is fixed and all
you need to do is to estimate a value
function and once you do this and then
it's used as a black box inside a
approximate policy iteration is a matter
algorithm to optimize the policy and
then the same Prime module formulation
can be used to derive a number of
previous gradient TD algorithms that
were derived in history historically
using different principles but now using
this idea you can derive them from very
standard optimization perspective
without all this area specific intuition
Petit's and the third thing that I have
talked about briefly just now is that
this formulation allow you to use while
established techniques from learning
statistics to understand the behavior of
the algorithm and also as I actually
gave this talk two years ago at
assignments in the same place that when
you look at the problem in this
primal-dual way you can use some of
these technology optimization techniques
such as stochastic variable reduce
gradient to reduce variance in a green
descent and result and obtain
exponential speed-up in convergence rate
so these are so these workers it's not
new this was done last year so next time
I would like to talk about something
that was done by saying that standard
approach because of this projection is
no longer you know attractive it loses
all the nice properties of the bellman
iteration so if you do experiments with
this new one for dqn or something does
it yes I yes I will have a experiments
later in the slides in the next section
it's very related it also comes from the
prime a dual formulation but as a
simplifying approximation as you may
wonder when we formulate a problem as
minimax it's much like a for example
can't problem where what optimization is
known to be very hard to do so can we do
some can we simplify the problem
generalizing the value function is what
we want because what we want is the
policy that we learn should be to behave
similarly on index beta right that's
right yes so the short answer is that in
these formulation in this formulation
the primal variables have both B and pi
so we solve it I've been saying V but
actually is solving V Empire at the same
time
and the longer answer is that there are
other algorithms that solve PI directly
without looking into B but then there
are in many cases is more effective to
also take advantage of these V
information this is actually the
principal Dunnan programming that allows
you to solve the problem more
effectively
okay so so now can we simplify the
pyramidal problem into a primal only
problem and the answer is yes in some
cases to explain what happen you look at
a simplified case where there's no
action well or the equivalent reactions
that is this has only one action so I
can remove PI and lambda and a
saturation and this primal do problem
become has this form without a and this
is the bellman error without a and the
same thing here now my restriction is to
restrict this new variable to reproduce
reproducing kernel Hilbert space
okay ensure this arcade rest is a hue /
space where the inner product can be
computed efficiently computed by a
kernel function so after I do this that
the nice thing to look at this is that
you can think of this as a soft
constraint that prevents these two
variable to be too big in L 2 norm okay
this is a soft constraint and then it
can be approximated by a hard constraint
usually the soft constraint is easy to
solve but now I'm going to do the
opposite way where we play this soft
constraint by a hard constraint so that
I restrict this new to be in the hueber
space and it's lies inside a unit ball
measured by this kernel norm and then
and they have this but without this soft
constraint term and the the reason I do
this is that once you write this problem
this way after using properties and
architectures I can show that this guy
has the closed form including this man
max the whole thing has a closed form
and this closed form has can be written
it this way here as a sample from any
data distribution that you have now this
term I have another s bar that are also
independently sample from the same data
distribution so as an S bar are in iid
and then
and then I computer great the bellman
Arab for s domina on s bar and waited by
the kernel function the kernel of s and
s bar then take the average and then you
get the same thing as before so so now
what I have done so far is to reduce the
prime module problem into a minimization
only problem and the trick is to use the
cockatrice property to to find a
closed-form solution for the minimax and
now end up with a new loss for solving
Bauman equation let's call it L sub K
this is what I copy from the previous
slide let's call this new function L sub
K similar to the Prime module problem
it's also well defined objective
function that doesn't require double
sample so I should mention that this is
not double sample it means that two
independent sample from state that you
can get from looking at drawing to
sample from your training set what the
sample means that the next time
the next day is prime starting from s or
s bar should be double so this is
different double sample and this can be
solved estimated from data and because
of this
yes wall will define objective function
and estimate it from data you can use
say stochastic we understand with many
batches to solve it then and then I and
that the paper has the details
how do you extend this case to the
control problem when you also want to
optimize policies
or is that it's outlined in this case
did you have a single action which one
are you talking about the script
oh oh this guy yeah if so write this is
that a closed-form right like the
solution is I mean the inverse are the
minimum function okay just an
observation
so okay so RSF fine but then so let's go
back to this am i misunderstand your
question but so from here are SF fine
but is some quantity some random Quan
some quantity okay it's a function and
then this function can this whole thing
with the max can be equivalently compute
this way
okay so I'm going to talk briefly about
what this function what is lost function
does
there's an interesting eigenfunction
interpretation versus theorem from the
kernel theory uh this kernel function
can be written in this way as the I
essentially project us it's embedded in
this represented by these eigen
functions yai yai
and then weighted by this lambda either
and positive scalars and with this
decomposition and this elf function can
be you can show that this LK it's
equivalent to this what is this it's
this is the bell mayor for states and
what it does is to project his pulmonary
on to these eigen functions average over
States so this is a projection and then
square so in a sense this loss function
is that Li weighted square out to norm
in space spanned by these eigen
functions and of course you can imagine
that different kernel functions lead to
different lambda IVI pairs as an example
we can use our gauss Colonel Gaussian
kernel and it's known that this Gaussian
kernel emphasize or put more weights on
smoother functions meaning that for
lower frequency functions then you have
this higher bigger lambdas so if you
apply a Gaussian kernel what it means is
that it is lost function with favor
smoother functions smoother value
functions
and so how do we extend this to the
control case where you have more actions
the diffident of options one is to
introduce the PI variable here and then
do the same the same kernel last trick
as before except that now instead of
having a kernel function on a pair of
states now you have a kernel function on
pairs of state actions and the same
thing applies it's more complicated if
it's the same thing
another option is to use the previous
last function assuming the policy is
fixed but then use it to as a black box
as a component in sy another matter
algorithm like approximate policy
iteration or active critique to solve
the policy valuation problem for example
in active critique this critic is
essentially solving V when actor the
policy is fixed so you can use this loss
function to learn a critique and then
use the credit update actor and I use
these loss function to update a tree in
this way so now the question now let's
go back to the starting point why we
have to go through this is that there's
a bad there benefits of looking at the
problem formulating the problem as
optimization and if you do this kind of
dynamic programming based approaches
it's known that the there is worsen for
examples that they lead to unstable
divergently behavior an example is from
boy and mooing it's it's called paddle
war it's essentially to continues
two-dimensional great world with puddles
the agent want to go from a star say to
it to the coast state while avoiding the
puddles if you apply new network and
solve the problem then they show in a
paper and it can be reproduced here that
the new network can converge to infinity
this is the case here so we have
different approaches here Kailas is our
approach what's important is the Green
Line PD and fit a value iteration these
two are the DP based approaches green
and blue you can see the green and blue
they diverse to infinity the magnitude
of the weights by the value the mean
square or the value function they go to
infinity because the Val function has to
make goes to infinity and then another
thing to mention is residual gradient
which ignores the double sample problem
so the gradient in Reseda gradient is
bias and we know that we expected learn
the wrong policy and indeed it is you
can see that the mean square doesn't
decay that much can actually increase
that we covered previously it's it's
making progress but then it's learning
relative slowly because solving the
primal do is not easy so it may require
and in contrast the K loss function we
can have fast decreasing mean square
measure this way and pulmonary so for
these two the lower the better we want
and and these two plots show that our
loss is more consistent more better
correlated with mean square of value
function and pulmonary the shape the the
slope is is there is not one but then
the the correlation is high meaning that
is the kernel loss the K loss is a good
sark a loss for reinforcement learning
problems and the same similar result can
be observed from corpo and mounting car
both classic examples where new networks
can diverge and we also look at more
challenging problems in what magical
control problems problems and we look at
our approach Kaela's and these two
dynamic programming based methods and
this bias gradient residual bias
gradient methods
[ __ ] and everything it's
used inside trust PCL which use Vala
function learning is a component so
everything is the same except that we
vary the algorithms for learning the
value function so that all comparisons
are fair again we see that a the red
curve current loss makes the is the best
performance
so to conclude so a few take-home
messages that it seems that now more
modern Aria requires people to go from
go beyond tabular linear cases that has
dominated the research in REO community
for a long time
and then when we talk about nonlinear
cases it seems the convergence
conditions for DP based methods become
very brittle it's very easy to break it
so that it it oscillate and divergent
and this is can be observed in practice
and it's a bottleneck for applying RL in
practice and then they were like
hopefully I have argued on this talk
that it's a promising and fruitful
approach to shift from dynamic
programming based approaches to
optimization driven approaches where you
want to formulate the problem is a
minimization or minimax function with
objective function and then do and then
solve it using more standard
optimization techniques and it has many
benefits such as improved conversions
and stronger theoretical guarantees also
it has more transparent behaviors you
can analyze what the algorithm is doing
using established techniques from
statistics and and finally this is not
just about theory the long term goal is
to show that look at this theory and
this new thinking can lead to algorithms
that are easier to solve easily using in
practice so that you don't have to worry
about different kind of strange behavior
the algorithm have them become more
comparable to support learning and you
can off the shelf so on Monday and then
there's this problem is join growing
interest in the community and and with a
few colleagues like Dell and bowtie and
and other people we are organizing and
workshop at Europe's this year the topic
is the optimization foundations of
reinforcement learning including
this fixpoint optimization also linear
programming and and other optimization
approaches to reinforcement learning and
welcome to to participate and contribute
thanks
[Applause]
so I guess back to my earlier question I
was saying that by saying that I get
these instabilities when you project the
bunching clock so then in the last part
you're using like yeah in a sense this
is you know scientist is doing what you
hear we want to be pi yeah I should
mention that although there's a kernel
component in the the loss function this
is different from the more traditional
kernel basement right here our value
functions are parameterized as new
Network and the kernel kernel function
is only used to construct the objective
function so the difference between this
and dqn essentially is that dqn the
objective function is different well the
optimization approach is different in DQ
n is based on dynamic programming so you
use the target network to construct a
target for requestion and I learn the
Learning Network and repeat the process
this is exactly dynamic programming and
we've seen that it can be unstable and
here instead of doing that we framed the
whole problem as a single optimization
problem
okay loss is K loss refers to the loss
function using the kernel that here this
is Colonel this loss function also K
here this loss function is about finding
the value function for a fixed policy
and this is what is needed by this trust
PCR algorithm I don't I I don't have to
explain the whole algorithm but
essentially it's like reason it has two
components one is to update the policy
the others to provide a value function
for that policy and all these algorithms
competing algorithms differ in how we
learn the value function given the same
policy
so that's so this is the colonel one
it's as you can think of that as a
simplified version of the speech
stateless is based on the primal dual
formulation and this kernel loss
function is approximated to the primer
to approximating the dual part
some curious in cases like if you take
smaller problems where you could
actually solve the dynamic programming
reasonably well and you have a sense of
how much you might in fact lose by doing
the restricting the function to be our
caches instead of actually doing the
full-blown max in the saddle point
good question that depends on how you
restrict your key address you know some
special cases
for example you have a problem that you
know that well if you have a using a
standard linear approximation and then
we use linear kernel and then these two
find the same solution and then if you
use the indicator function in the kernel
to maybe the top product then you find a
model based RL so everyone collapsed the
same thing in this simple special cases
but in general nonlinear cases and then
they start to diverge well they started
to be different in other words
okay let's take a speaker again